bienvenue à part à l'automne si c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine j'ai
envie de vous parler de l'importance des
mots particulièrement due au fait qu'on
parle beaucoup des terminologies autour
de la militance autour des changements
sociaux et comment ces mots-là se
transforme justement à mesure que les
luttes avance la raison étant très
faible c'est que j'ai vu beaucoup de
débats par rapport à black ops martin
levy noire sont importantes a dit jean
marc levy autochtones sont importantes
et d'autres termes en allant jusqu'à ows
marin toutes les vies sont importants
donc la raison étant qu'il ya un énorme
débauche justement pour dire que
blacklight maroc oui mais et le jeans
nightmare eux aussi oui mais alive
marins aussi et ses débats de l'angle de
linguistique le ont aussi un grand
rapport par rapport justement à la
priorité à la priorisation des luttes
mais aussi un peu un effacement
justement de certains des enjeux donc on
veut parler
je vais essayer de démêler le plus
simplement possible black white marin
c'est un mouvement qui est extrêmement
présent aux états unis on sait que
historiquement le racisme systémique qui
existe aux états unis et tournait
vraiment beaucoup autour de la
population noire de l'esclavagé noir
aussi qui est omniprésent aux états unis
pendant quand même très longtemps alors
qu'au canada on va avoir beaucoup
entendu parler de lévis autochtone sont
importants puisqu'on parle beaucoup plus
du racisme systémique institutionnalisé
qui existe au canada autour des
communautés autochtones
c'est à dire les réserves ça disons des
pensionnats les sixties coupe et tout le
mécanisme gouvernementale qui a été mis
en place justement pour contrôler les
populations autochtones la discuter avec
tout ça c'est que dans un débat
justement qui
kylie deux pays justement sur le racisme
systémique
on va avoir tendance à entendre des gens
dire oui mais un jeans nightmare heures
quand on va parler de black-out
marcheurs et aux états unis
on va voir quand même dans la mouvance
de blackwater une énorme coopération qui
suit la mobilisation autochtone qui
existe aux états unis comme avec
american indian mouvement pour pouvoir
justement lutter contre les formes de
racisme systémique
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
en dix ans marc gini style marin je n'ai
pas une compétition ce n'est pas un
concours à gagner sur qui doit être le
plus important qu'elle est la ville la
plus importante à gagner on parle d'une
lutte sur le moment sur des enjeux qui
sont extrêmement importants sur le
moment et malheureusement le racisme est
systémique et un stylet ayant créé des
ce qu'on appelle du racisme internaliser
chez beaucoup de personnes qui sont
repris mais justement alors des
autochtones qui vont voir des noirs de
façon raciste parce qu'on leur a
enseigné que même étaient des personnes
- est importante donc sûrement quelqu'un
d'encore moins important en dessous
d'eux ce sont des enseignements qu'on a
entendu étant jeune et que je vois
justement réfléter dans certaines
réflexions sur la prom' la provenance
que prend le mouvement black avec marc
au canada et c'est une espèce de parts
que justement cette mouvance autour du
racisme noir va prendre le dessus autour
de la discussion qui parle du racisme
contre des communautés autochtones
alors vous imaginez comment dans
luttes de personnes qui sont opprimés
quand c'est rendu qu'on ait fait de
savoir c'est lui trop de vent ce n'est
pas un problématique de savoir qui elle
est la lutte la plus importante c'est
une problématique de voir qui on essaie
d'être des qui on va avoir la tension
est aussi la durée d'attention des gens
face à une nouvelle situation face à de
nouveaux mouvements ou face à des
terminologies qui vont devenir en
compétition et on a même vu aux états
unis pertinence et des bols existe c'est
le alive marc oui mais toutes les vies
sont importants et certains des aspects
autour de ça c'est vraiment de dire eh
bien oui toutes les villes sont
importantes c'est pour ça qu'on parle du
sujet de maths et jeunes live majeur
parce que présentement six villas dans
le système dans lequel ils sont pris non
pas justement accès à l'eau même niveau
que toutes les eaux live maroc on veut
supposément faire croire qu'ils sont le
co2 tournons donc en utilisant des fois
le code le code alive marin on a une
tendance à pousser des fois sans fard en
compte la suprématie du message comme
quoi il n'y en a pas de racisme
systémique non il n'a pas de problème
ils se plaignent pour rien ça n'existe
pas donc c'est toujours très important
de voir quel genre de terminologie qui
existait quand même auparavant sont
utilisés ou réutilisés pour pouvoir
provoquer justement des débats ou pour
pouvoir effacer des débats et même ce
qu'on va appeler du dogue westling c'est
à dire du sifflet à chier c'était en
attendant certains terne que pour
l'heure la grande population n'ont pas
de signification spéciale pour des
personnes qui sont dans ces gros plans
qui sont touchés par des luttes
on va voir des termes tizi pour promener
à provoquer justement cette ce réflexe
face aux homos on va penser
particulièrement à dans un autre camp
justement la destination à la population
lgbt q2 est ce qui autrefois était juste
gay ou coin et on utilisait un terme
panier pour pouvoir tout définir alors
spécifiant certains terminologie par
rapport à l'identité par rapport à la
lutte on spécifie les loutres justement
qui sont distinctes les unes des autres
donc en utilisant black mic mac os on
n'efface pas des luttes de racisme
systémique autour des autochtones mais
on faire ressortir justement des aspects
qui sont spécifiques à la lutte contre
le racisme envers la population noire
contre la racisme envers la population
autochtone quand c'est le cas donc les
mots sont importants et je vois qu'il ya
beaucoup aussi de rien flex très
viscéral par rapport à la création ou à
l'adoption de nouveaux termes dans le
vocabulaire comme donc racisme
systémique et un terme qu'on débat
encore ici au québec comme étant un
terme annoncent existe pas le système
n'est pas raciste il y ait des gens
racisme c'est que des nouveaux termes
vont toujours être adoptés ils vont
toujours venir se présenter à mesure que
les luttes s'éclaircissent et là je
pense particulièrement à l'est puis
justement d'une forme de système le
dictionnaire webster qui cette semaine
justement à la suite d'une rue de la
raquette d'une femme en particulier a
décidé de réviser le terme racisme et
pour y inclure le mot le terme racisme
système et ils disent que ça fait
tellement longtemps que le mot n'a pas
été repensé dans le dictionnaire webster
un dictionnaire anglais que
c'est ça vaut la peine d'en parler et
surtout dans le débat particulièrement
du fait que disent que les mots ne
devrait pas être pensé ou réfléchit en
fonction justement d'une idéologie mais
le fait de ne pas reconnaître que
certains termes existe et de ne pas
vouloir les rajouter à mesure que la
lutte que les changements sociaux
arrivent serait en même temps prendre
une position sur ces termes là donc même
les dictionnaires révise constamment les
mots qui vont utiliser donc il ne faut
pas avoir peur des nouveaux mots qui s'y
présentent ne peut pas avoir pas non
plus de voir que les îles vont s'adapter
aux couleurs de des débats contemporains
et que c'est le club ne sont pas en
compétition ou en concours l'une contre
l'autre mais qu'il faut transformer
cette espèce datant parce que c'est un
concours de popularité par rapport à
quelqu'un qui nous écoutons qui nous
regardent donc il faut se donner la
place et il faut créer cette solidarité
entre les mots sans vouloir en faire un
grand mont panié et je pense souvent aux
mots autochtone qui est utilisée au
canada qui est bien mieux que les
indiens ou les savage qu'on utilisait
autrefois qui a évolué et tranquillement
le mot autochtone était un mot panier
est en train de se faire remplacer par
les noms des nations des personnes qui
les utilisent donc autrefois j'aurais
fait une une sauvage j'étais devenue une
indienne maintenant une autochtone et
dans quelques années les gens vont
toujours m'identifier par rapport à ma
nation innu quelqu'un qui est mort quand
quelqu'un quitte abénakis alors vous
pouvez voir le pouvoir des mots est
extrêmement important et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya de l'espace pour pouvoir en
apprendre et en créer de nouveaux à
chaque année alors merci beaucoup pour
votre écoute
j'espère que vous allez partager vidéos
j'espère aussi que vous y serez pas un
métier commentaires ou des questions si
ça vous tente
bonne semaine